le gouvernement est de ne pas confiné
malgré des situations tendues dans
certaines régions moi je vous dirai ce
que j'ai dit depuis des mois je n'ai pas
varié je ne vais pas faire de polémique
sur le sujet je pense que le confinement
est la pire des solutions
une solution archaïque moyen-âgeuse dont
les conséquences en 2d c'est à dire les
conséquences psychologiques sociales
économiques sont absolument dramatiques
peut-être même doit-on le dire pire
encore que le mal que l'on souhaite
guérir lorsqu'on est sur des opérations
de confinement massive et donc depuis le
départ je dis que tout ce qui peut nous
permettre d'éviter le confinement il
nous faut l'éviter il n'y a pas lieu à
polémiquer je pense que cette ligne là
et celles qu'il faut tenir
est-ce que la situation sanitaire
permettra de la tenir c'est une autre
question parce que la réalité quelle est
elle la réalité c'est que seule la
vaccination massive permettra
véritablement d'éviter des solutions
aussi brutale que le confinement et sur
les citations est-ce que vous somme nous
sommes très très en temps on va on va en
parler avec respect mais est ce que vous
comprenez la ligne quand vous voyez que
dunkerque est confiné kunis et le
littoral des alpes-maritimes est confiné
des régions comme l'ile-de-france où il
ya une saturation hospitalière ne le
sont pas ce que je vous dis vaut pour
l'ensemble du territoire
je pense que les opérations de
confinement sont extrêmement durs et
néfaste partout n'y a pas deux poids
deux mesures et ça vaut y compris les
patients malgré le coût que ça implique
que confiné
d'après vous il vaut mieux vacciner
massivement nous confiner dans l'instant
attentes mais voyez vous depuis le début
vous voyez bien qu'on est en train de
gérer une situation de de misère au fond
puisque nous n'avons pas les moyens nous
n'avons ne sommes pas donné les moyens
de lutter efficacement contre cette
épidémie est donc moi je refuse d'aller
chercher les solutions les plus durs
alors même que nous avons des
alternatifs et notamment la vaccination
massive si nous accélérions vraiment pas
dans les mots pendant lé slogan est
vraiment sur le terrain la vaccination
massive
alors nous pourrions durablement éviter
les opérations de confinement
ça passe par quoi accélérer la
réconciliation d'abord ça passe par des
commandes plus massive
pardon de dire que nous avons évité un
débat qui nous dérange sûrement
collectivement en france mais qui le
fait que notre pays est celui qui aura
eu le moins accès en volume au vaccin
produits y compris certaines industries
pharmaceutique française qui parce que
la france ne les a pas accompagné son
talent et produire le vaccin pour des
pays voisins notamment pour la grande
bretagne
c'est ça dit tout de la situation de
délitement d'effondrement de la
souveraineté de notre de notre nation
c'est la première chose accéléré sur le
volume et ensuite sur le déploiement
coûté les décrets qui ont permis
notamment aux médecins généralistes de
vacciner ont mis des semaines des
semaines le décrit a mis des semaines à
sortir aujourd'hui on devrait pouvoir
généraliser la vaccination par les
pharmaciens
on commence à tester pour voir ce que ça
donne mais l'administration se couvre
autant quelques tours de l'arrivée
seront ils pourront rexel évidemment
évidemment mais on a pris trop de préco
pas des précautions
on a pris trop de trop de temps à
alimenter la machine administrative se
sont pas des précautions coûter soyons
clair nos pharmaciens sont parfaitement
capables de vacciner contre la coved ils
le font déjà sur sur d'autres d'autres
épidémies saisonnières
donc c'est pas d'hésitation tout ça
c'est la lourdeur d'une machine
administrative et d'hommes politiques
qui est devenu faible dans notre pays
sur la vaccination on voit que les
soignants sont assez réticents à se
faire vacciner sont un tiers seulement
être vaccinés à ce qu'ils feront de
cette vaccination obligatoire
c'est un vrai débat vrai questionnement
sur ce sujet d'abord je voudrais
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays
nous avons des métiers pour lesquels un
centre de vaccination sont obligatoires
c'est notamment le cas pour le personnel
qui travaille dans la petite enfance
quand j'étais maire certainement
personnel en crèche nom personnel en
crèche ont une série de vaccinations
obligatoires
je pense que c'est pas absurde parce que
dans un cas comme celui-ci c'est
totalement liés au métier qu'ils
exercent
et puis pour ce qui est des soignants je
ne conçois pas que nos soignants
refusent la vaccination
ça pose le vrai sujet comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là
comment avons nous pu dans un pays comme
le nôtre le pays de pasteur organiser
les choses faillir sur la communication
et sur l'information autour du vaccin
à tel point que des soignants car ceux
qui ont tenu dans cette bataille
sanitaires aujourd'hui refuserait de se
faire vacciner mais là où j'ai un doute
c'est que je pense que cette démarche de
l'obligation vaccinale ne règle pas le
problème
je pense même que ça crispe que ça
coince et qu'au fond celles et ceux qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
et auront des raisons encore plus fort
de ne pas le faire si on les y oblige
vous parlez vous disiez le confinement
c'est là c'est la pire des solutions
le gouvernement est en train de
réfléchir à réouvrir certains lieux
comme les restaurants les salles de
sport grâce à un pass vaccinale est ce
que vous pensez que ça c'est une bonne
solution
en attendant la vaccination de tous qui
n'interviendra pas avant la fin de l'été
visiblement non c'est une mauvaise
solution pour une raison très simple
nous n'avons pas besoin d'un pass
vaccinale pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire dans une salle de cinéma pas
sanitaire pendant des mois dans une
salle de cinéma
on peut parfaitement dans une salle de
cinéma comme dans une salle de spectacle
comme dans un restaurant organiser
l'espace pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de risque sanitaire
moi ce que je ne veux pas c'est que nous
basculions progressivement dans une
société d'hygiène isation permanente
dans une société où l'aspect sanitaire
effacerait toute autre considération de
liberté individuelle
je sais qu au coeur d'une crise
sanitaire c'est compliqué de dire ça
mais c'est je pense la responsabilité
d'un député d'un élu de la nation garant
des libertés de dire que nous devons
sortir de cette crise avec les mêmes
libertés que nous avions auparavant pas
avec des libertés rabougri amoindri et
cette question du passé ni blair qui
ouvre la porte y compris au pass
vaccinale parce qu'au fond c'est une
manière d'en trouve rire cette porte là
pour moi est une erreur nous avons
d'autres solutions
utilisons toutes les autres solutions
d'organisation sanitaire
je profite pour lancer un appel solennel
à la ministre de la culture
ça suffit ré ouvrir les espaces de
culture réouvrir lieu de culture ils
sont près d'un point de vue sanitaire et
d'un point de vue d'organisation et ce
sont des lieux dans notre pays a un
besoin absolument vital on n'est pas un
grand pays comme la france on ne
traverse pas une situation de guerre
sanitaires comme celle que nous
traversons sans avoir ces lieux de
respiration ces lieux de culture et
d'expression de la liberté qui sont les
lieux de la vie culturelle nationale
justement il ya une réunion
réunion ce matin à matignon entre les
acteurs de la culture jean castex et et
roselyne bachelot
il ya des mobilisations des acteurs de
la culture qui se multiplient dans
certains théâtres et roselyne bachelot
hier elle était devant les sénateurs
pour les questions d'actu elle parlait
d' occupation inutile voire dangereuse
car ses occupations mettant menace des
lieux patrimoniaux fragile qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ça moi je pense que
roselyne bachelot cherche depuis des
semaines à s'excuser d'être impuissante
pardon de le dire mais on voit bien que
depuis le début la ministre de la
culture
ça n'enlève rien à l'affection que je
pourrais lui porter la ministre la
culture ne peut rien ne fait rien sur
ces sujets et la question c'est la
volonté politique est ce que nous en
sommes arrivés dans ce grand pays qu'est
la france a considéré que la culture est
un sujet absolument secondaire enfin
pardon de faire des rappels historiques
mais même au coeur des grands moments de
guerre dans notre pays des grands
moments de tension notre pays les lieux
de culture ont toujours été ceux qui ont
préservé une expression notamment des
libertés est une expression de la
respiration intellectuelle en vain
gouvernement considère la peinture comme
secondaire aujourd'hui s'il l'a
considéré comme prioritaire
il aurait déjà travaillé avec tous les
acteurs de la culture pour réouvrir ces
lieux mais vous savez moi je travaille
beaucoup cette question de la culture
dans le cadre des élections régionales
nous en parlerons je porterai un plan de
soutien massif à la culture parce que je
suis certain que si nous n'agissons pas
vite
l'ensemble de des acteurs de la culture
de notre non seulement les lieux de
spectacle les lieux de cinéma mais aussi
tout le tout le champ de la production
de la réalisation va s'effondrer et pour
le rayonnement de la nation pour le
rayonnement la nation pour la vie de
chacun de nos concitoyens ont plu au
plus juste du département rural cela
manquera terriblement comment on fait
pour réouvrir ses salles sans pass
sanitaire ce que vous y êtes opposé
quelques collègues sénateurs a
parfaitement poser les choses
aujourd'hui nous nous réunissions dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale ou
du sénat avec des masques en ce
nettoyant les mains un siège sur deux en
gardant mon distance avec une entrée et
une sortie j'étais pour tout vous dire
avec les responsables d'un grand musée
parisien il ya quelques quelques jours
j'étais dans ma région il ya quelques
quelques semaines on peut parfaitement
dans ces grands espaces de musées
organisée
d'entrée une sortie on peut parfaitement
dans un cinéma qui n'a jamais un taux de
remplissage supérieur à 50% faire en
sorte qu'un siège sur deux ne soit pas
occupé
il faut simplement faire preuve d'un peu
de bon sens dans les restaurants comme
en fait dans les restaurants on peut
tout à fait éloigner les tables on peut
tout à fait respecté la mine nations les
plus non personne personne n'a jamais
démontré que les restaurants étaient des
foyers épidémiques salon on a on à
écrire des espèces de des espèces de de
deux totems de cette manière là on
considérant que les restaurants étaient
des acteurs l'épidémie ce qui n'est pas
vrai ils ont été d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils
ont réouvert pardon de le dire mais à
destination de nos restaurateurs
absolument exemplaire plus sur les
règles de saine et et un respect le
masque en fait qui au moment du déjeuner
on peut trouver des solutions y compris
de distanciation sur sur la même table
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui des personnes qui
travaillent dans un même endroit des
jeunes à midi dans une même salle
parfois même dans des conditions très
difficiles moi je me suis battu dans mon
département pour réouvrir les
restaurants pour les ouvriers des
travaux publics qui dg dans un fourgon
les uns à côté des autres
voilà les solutions que nous pourrons
apporter réouvrir les lieux qui peuvent
l'être et on va parler d'un autre sujet
d'actualité ce sont ces violences qui se
multiplient entre jacques creyssel oui
je déjeune de plus en plus jeunes
qu'est-ce qu'on veut mettre en place
pour pour éviter ça d'abord un constat
que je partage avec vous le l'ultra
violence sur des publics qui sont de
plus en plus jeunes moi je suis effrayé
effrayé de voir d'abord le niveau de
violence et de voir le délitement de
l'autorité républicaine parce qu'au fond
d'eux ce dont il s'agit c'est cela il y
à des zones entières dans notre pays
dans lesquels la république n'a plus
aucune autorité la première des règles
c'est de rétablir cette autorité avec
des forces une force qu'une faute
collective gouvernement évidemment on a
tous contribuer d'une certaine manière à
cette situation je serais malhonnête si
je le disais pas je peux dire aussi que
la droite républicaine et nicolas
sarkozy a beaucoup fait notamment sur la
question des banlieues pas seulement sur
le rétablissement de l'autorité mais
aussi sur la mixité sociale
je discutais avec jean louis borloo il
ya quelques quelques semaines et nous
discutions du fait que ces espaces
urbains sont devenus de véritables
ghettos
vous rajoutez à cela une défaillance de
autorités familial qui est un véritable
sujet et vous avez cette situation
catastrophique soit attaqué la
responsabilité des parents est ce qu'il
faut remettre sur la table la
suppression des allocations familiales
pour je pense qu'il faut avoir le
courage de faire ce qui est nécessaire
moi je suis favorable à ce que nous
rediscuterons de la question de la
suspension des allocations familiales
pour les parents qui faillit spa les
parents qui ne réussissent pas qu'ils se
battent pour que leurs enfants soient
dans le droit chemin mais qui ne
parviennent pas à ça existe aussi
non je parle de tous ceux qui ont
abandonné leur mission d'autorité
parentale je n'ai aucun tabou sur ce
sujet et je pense que ce serait une
mesure juste juste à l'égard de ceux qui
n'assument pas leurs responsabilités
de la même manière je considère qu'il
faut désormais pour les jeunes
délinquants
une peine rapide et immédiate qui
souhaitent une peine d'encadrement
militaire
je n'ai aucun problème sur ce sujet nous
avions à l'époque sont nicolas sarkozy
notamment développer les centres fermés
les centres éducatifs avec un
encadrement militaire
madame taubira a mis fin à ces
dispositifs pour des raisons
idéologiques et aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'on a très peu de nouveaux centres qui
ont été ouverts savez sur ce sujet de la
sécurité
gérald darmanin emmanuel macron font les
matamores et montrent leurs muscles qui
parlent fort et au final lorsqu'il
s'agit d'agir ça fait pschitt
il n'y a plus rien ou pas grand chose
donc vous considérer qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple la prison n'est pas forcément la
solution à la prison telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui n'est pas la
solution pour les gamins de 15 ans mais
mais mais la la la liberté n'est pas non
plus la solution il faut trouver un
outil intermédiaire moi je refuse qu'on
mette des gamins de 15 ans au milieu de
voyous de 50 ans pour qu il se
radicalise peut-être davantage encore
pour ceux qui sont dans cette voie là
mais je refuse aussi qu'on les laisse en
liberté
ce que je souhaite c'est que nous les
ayons un outil d'autorité intermédiaire
et je pense que l'autorité militaire
peut être la solution d'encadrement pour
ces jeunes là un mot on va parler des
républicains et de votre campagne
aurélien pradié mai
un mot qui fait l'actu entre les
républicains et cette semaine on était
la semaine du 8 mars votre parti a tenu
une convention je crois le 8 mars vous y
étiez d'ailleurs autour de plusieurs
élus mais votre parti il est loin d'être
exemplaire sur ces questions période de
parité vous payez chaque année une
amende assez conséquente d'un 7 millions
est ce que vous allez agir sur ce sujet
de la parité oui nous y sommes d'abord
depuis plusieurs semaines nous
travaillons avec christian jacob qui
tiennent beaucoup à être le plus en
règle possible sur cette question de la
parité c'est pas un sujet simple ça ne
se fait pas en claquant des doigts il
faut être très très honnête mais c'est
un objectif que nous nous sommes fixés
tous les partis politiques sont dans une
situation difficile
à cet égard comme d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'entreprises c'est un fait national
fait de société mais je dois vous dire
aussi que la question de la préservation
des droits des femmes vaut pour la
parité vaut aussi pour la protection des
femmes et ce point de vue les
républicains ont une longue histoire et
une belle histoire de protection des
droits des femmes
c'est simone veil avec lille et g c'est
en somme de loi que nous avons fait
voter c'est celle que j'ai pu porter et
faire voter à l'assemblée nationale pour
protéger les femmes victimes de
violences avec notamment la
généralisation du bracelet anti
rapprochement sur ce sujet la droite
républicaine on l'a peut être oublié à
une grande belle et longue histoire de
protection mais cédé face et pour
lesquels c'est plus difficile pour les
question d'élection il faut peut-être
déloger des élus déjà en place depuis
longtemps qu'ils sont si c'est un
travail difficile c'est certain ça vaut
pour les femmes ça vaut pour la jeune
génération et c'est un sujet qui
concerne la respiration de notre
démocratie c'est aussi pour ça ou
engageant son nombre d'élections
notamment les élections régionales parce
que je pense qu'un enfant peut notamment
une nouvelle génération puisse prendre
prendre ses responsabilités par les deux
bouts
un magazine a récemment qu'il serait un
portrait de vous le cerveau gauche de la
droite
est-ce que cela vous définit bien non
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça veut dire
que je vais partir du cerveau ce qui ce
qui sera rassurant plus sérieusement ma
sensibilité c'est la sensibilité
gaulliste je me suis engagé en politique
très jeune je viens d'une famille qui
n'a jamais fait de politique c'est pas
mon milieu initial j'ai été élu à 21 ans
dans ma terre du lot comme le jeune
conseiller général époque j'ai battu mon
instituteur et j'ai toujours été élu en
cette terre du lot - élus de droite
alors que l'eau est une terre de gauche
et pourtant je ne suis pas de gauche je
suis de droite d'une droite populaire
d'une droite
fier de ses convictions d'une droite qui
est capable de tendre la main aux plus
fragiles
ce que nous avons historiquement fait
c'est une des grandes sensibilités
notamment de jacques chirac
bref j'ai pas du tout le sentiment de de
dévier de ce qu'est la droite
républicaine à laquelle je crois
il faut une complémentarité de
l'autorité et une capacité je le redis à
être attentif aux plus humbles
c'est le sens de mon engagement
politique depuis depuis mes 20 ans mais
c'est une mine qui était devenu atypique
chez les élèves
aujourd'hui est ce que vous avez est ce
que vous arrivez à vous faire longtemps
parce que vous n'avez pas de mal à vous
faire entendre
on sait que la ligne économique que vous
avez que vous avez défendu a du mal à
infuser chez l air comment ça se passe
vous l'aurez compris j'aime les défis
difficiles il ya une fracture
aujourd'hui dans votre partie non il n'y
a pas de fracture ya un débat et c'est
sain selon nous a reproché à droite de
ne plus avoir d'idées depuis des années
pas nous reproche aujourd'hui d'avoir
trop d'idées et font les questions nous
posons des questions tout à fait
fondamental si nous sortons des
caricatures lorsque je dis que le modèle
économique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui celui de l'ubs et risation
de l'économie demi fictive celui de de
la fuite de notre richesse vers d'autres
pays du monde c'est pas le modèle
économique que nous souhaitons ce que
nous souhaitons c'est une économie qui
soit juste
c'est le travailler plus pour gagner
plus de nicolas sarkozy c'était
exactement cela c'était pas être béat
face à la production de richesses
c'était souhaité la production de
richesses pour que chacun s'y retrouve
et que nous soyons justes avec le mérite
de chacun
je crois que ce discours là cette
sensibilité là d'une économie au service
des femmes et des hommes au service d'un
projet national
c'est une sensibilité qui peut
rassembler toute la droite républicaine
et j'y travaille et le reste il encore
tenable cette ligne politique d'aider
les plus faibles à un moment où on sait
bien que les efforts faits par par
l'état ont été énormes depuis le début
la crise du coc vide que la dette est en
train de s'élargir
vous proposiez par exemple 300 jobs pour
des jeunes dans des institutions d'état
est ce que ça ne va pas encore plus
creusé le trou de la dette sur ses plus
sujet de la droite finalement la dette
gens bien sûr que si le la dette et le
sujet de la droite j'ai d'ailleurs
beaucoup travaillé avec françois baroin
et et agnès evren sur ce sujet il nous
faudra rembourser cette dette sur une
télé à mon sens plus long que nous
l'imaginons aujourd'hui parce que c'est
une dette exceptionnelle scène coco vide
mais sur la question des jeunes soyons
précis
nous savons aujourd'hui 700 mille jeunes
qui vont rentrer sur le marché du
travail dans une situation
incroyablement dégradé trois cent mille
de ces jeunes environ ont perdu leur
petit job c'est à dire des petits jobs
que des jeunes étudiants en bac + 5
avait aujourd'hui dans un restaurant etc
etc
ces jeunes là dans quelques mois il
faudra leur trouver une solution je
parle pas des jeunes décrocheurs de ceux
qui avaient du mal à trouver un boulot
je parle de jeunes qui se rend bac +5 et
qui ont perdu leurs petits jobs qui sont
les nouveaux pauvres qui sont ceux qui
font la queue pour aller chercher à
manger
qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
considère que ce n'est pas un problème
qui ne font rien proposé et bien moi je
préfère proposer à ces jeunes un petit
boulot qui sera prise en charge en
partie par les collectivités et l'état
plutôt que demain de voir leur pays rsa
jeunes qui ne les sortirait pas de la
misère et je préférerai toujours de
bonnes dépenses publiques de bonnes
dépenses publiques qui protège notre
jeunesse qui ne sacrifie pas notre
avenir à des dépenses publiques inutiles
on fera le ménage ans qui ne sert à rien
pour le concentré sur ce qui peut être
utile et la jeunesse c'est plus qu'utile
alors on va aller en occitanie avec vos
critères l on va parler de votre
candidature aux régionales aurélien
pradié donc oui vous êtes candidat aux
élections régionales depuis très peu de
temps qu'est ce qui vous a fait changer
d'avis on avait cru comprendre que vous
n'aviez pas très envie d'y aller
qu'est-ce-qui qui a créé la bascule
c'est le sens du courage ça va vous
paraître un peu pompeux peut-être mais
c'est ce qui m'a déterminé
je pense que la politique c'est d'abord
une affaire de courage c'est vrai que
cette bataille est difficile elle sera
difficile pour ma famille politique mais
je pense au savoir le sondage réalisé
par l'ifop pour les républicains
d'ailleurs qui vous donne troisième à 13
%
dernière carole delga la présidente
sortante à 28% et jean paul garraud le
candidat du rassemblement national à 26
une parenthèse sur les sondages à chaque
fois que j'étais candidat dans une
élection notamment dans le lot on
m'annonce est largement perdant donc les
sondages ne m'impressionne pas mais
cette notion de courage elle est pour
moi fondamental en politique et c'est ce
qui m'a convaincu d'aller tenir le
drapeau d'aller mener la bataille ma
candidature c'est aussi une garniture de
clarté nous aurons dans cette campagne
les habitants l'occitanie auront le
choix entre de nombreuses girouette de
nombreux caméléon ceux qui sont
candidats de la république en marche
mais qui veulent pas le dire qu'ils ont
trahi leur famille politique à droite
pour aller se vendre au plus offrant
parce que c'était plus facile d'être
candidat de la république en marche du
candidat dont j'ai d'ailleurs oublié nom
qui sera candidat pour la république en
marche mais qui a peur de le dire ça
vaut aussi pour l'extrême droite les
candidats de l'extrême droite n'ose plus
dire qu'ils sont front national ou
rassemblement national et puis vous
savez cette région c'est ma région
j'y suis né et j'ai grandi c'est là où
j'ai fait l'essentiel tout mon
engagement politique je suis pas un
parachuté dans cette région au contraire
elles portent mes racines et je pense
que ce sera le moment de dire à nos
électeurs qu'après un quart de siècle de
gestion socialiste c'est long un quart
de siècle
surtout quand c'est une gestion
socialiste il est peut être temps
d'avoir une respiration et ce sera mon
engagement de faire respirer cette
région et qu'une nouvelle génération ne
restent pas planqué ne reste pas au
chaud mais aille à la bataille lorsqu'il
s'agit de la mener vous avez dit lorsque
vous avez accordé cette interview à la
dépêche du midi je prends date on a
l'impression que c'est une manière de
préparer vos électeurs à une défaite
est-ce que c'est comme ça que vous le
nom j'ai simplement dit que la confiance
était un temps long c'est lorsque j'ai
été élu député du lot je n'ai pas été
immédiatement la politique c'est pas une
affaire de coup politique c'est pas une
affaire de tentative qui réussit à
chaque fois c'est comme dans la vie il
faut batailler il faut marquer des pas
réussir à avancer et depuis plusieurs
jours je vois la dynamique depuis mon
annonce de candidature dans cette région
autour de jean luc moudenc le maire de
toulouse autour de très nombreuses
locaux qui me soutient depuis la
première heure et qui est très beau mer
est très bon maire une très belle ville
qui est qui et toulouse toute cette
équipe qui localement est en train de se
former ne pousse à vous dire que dans
tous les cas nous aurons une surprise et
que dans tous les cas notre famille
politique et au delà la droite le sandre
toutes celles et ceux qui ont besoin
aujourd'hui d'avoir une nouvelle
respiration dans cette région trouveront
dans notre candidature une alternative
beaucoup plus crédible notamment que
celle de l'extrême droite qui n'est là
que pour agiter dans cette région qui
n'a pas du tout l'ambition de gérer
cette région et qui d'ailleurs n'a
n'aurait pas les capacités vous savez
j'ai été conseiller régional pendant
plusieurs années et j'ai vu le
comportement des conseillers régionaux
du front national et si leurs électeurs
les avait vus se comporter au conseil
régional
il en aurait eu honte je les ai vus
revenir quasiment tome 1 quasiment tome
1 ils n'ont aucune volonté de gérer
cette région et il faut que nous
puissions nous la droite républicaine
courageusement apporter des solutions
aux habitants de perpignan de béziers de
tous ceux qui s'interrogent notamment
sur les questions de sécurité pour leur
montrer que le courage il est chez nous
c'est à eux que vous allez vous adresser
pour cette campagne
je m'adresserai à tous les électeurs et
à tous les habitants l'occitanie jeunes
en oublierait aucun des plus ruraux
plusieurs bains ceux qui ont des vrais
problèmes de sécurité comme ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas je m'adresserai aux plus
fragiles comme aux plus favorisés
c'est l'ambition la droite républicaine
c'est de rassembler toutes celles et
ceux qui ont aujourd'hui besoin et envie
de croire que la politique peut changer
les choses
alors en cas de second tour
rassemblement national contre la
présidente de région
carole delga est-ce que vous la
soutiendrait ce coupé dire ça déjà
aujourd'hui je vous ai dit que ma
candidature était une candidature de
clarté l'ambition d'un candidat de
droite c'est pas d'être là l'eau comme
la le second wagon
2 du front national ou des socialistes
ma liste mais la question du mécanisme
de se poser dans votre région aurélien
pradié alice assemblée nationale il
donnait accès au mal qu'est ce que vous
ferez tour sera celle du second tour je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas de retrait
pas d'alliance évidemment que non ni
retrait ni alliance la confiance des
électeurs est seulement la confiance des
électeurs et vous savez ce qui fait
aujourd'hui que les mouvements les plus
durs sont aux portes peut-être de
prendre certaines responsabilités c'est
parce que depuis des années les partis
politiques ont été lâche qu'ils ont cru
qu'il fallait se vendre et tripatouiller
pour éviter le verdict électoral moi je
n'ai pas peur du verdict électoral
ma liste du premier tour sera celle du
second tour je ne trie pas tout irait
pas entre les deux tours c'est un
engagement que je prends fermement
devant les habitants d'occitanie et
dernière question cristal beaucoup oui
une dernière question sur sur le coeur
de votre programme vous avez dit
toujours dans la dépêche que vous
souhaitiez travaillé sur les outils
d'accélération en matière économique
qu'est ce que ça signifie nous avons une
région qui a un potentiel extraordinaire
en matière agricole en matière
d'alimentation en matière économique et
industriel je pense à l'aéronautique
notamment airbus qui est en grande
difficulté jusque est en grande
difficulté qui va avoir besoin tout le
secteur aéronautique d'une vraie
mutation vers d'autres formes de métier
et c'est le rôle de la région de
soutenir toutes les innovations à venir
la filière hydrogène par exemple pour
airbus nous sommes en train de
travailler notamment sur la filière
hydrogène mais je vais très au delà je
pense que toutes les technologies et
tout le savoir-faire aéronautique peut
servir y compris sur la domotique c'est
à dire des outils du quotidien
il faudra que la région occitanistes
qu'elle fait peut aujourd'hui sortent du
saupoudrage sortent du petit
accompagnement pour porter une véritable
ambition au service de cette économie là
et donc au service de l'emploi ce sera
le premier axe une région qui innovent
et une région qui protège je ferai des
propositions très fortes notamment pour
la jeunesse pour protéger les plus
fragiles et pour protéger toutes celles
et ceux qui en ont besoin en matière de
sécurité dans les semaines qui viennent
j'irai partout en occitanie ce sera mon
engagement et mon tour d'occitanie et
chaque semaine nous porterons des
propositions qui sortiront l'ordinaire
et qui diront l'ambition nous avons pour
l'occitane vous allez rendre visite
aussi aux salariés de bosch qui a
annoncé plusieurs centaines de
licenciements sept semaines j'irai dans
tous les regards industriels à rodez qui
qui ont une difficulté beauchamp fait
partie nous avons un vrai vrai sujet
d'accompagnement de la mutation de cette
industrie et de préservation de l'emploi
dans un moment où nous avons besoin de
tous les emplois et merci beaucoup merci
anciens pas d'être venu un nouveau hors
jeu précise que demain on sera justement
[Musique]